This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. This is the American Dream of Freedom on Wheels, an automotive age, traveling on time-saving super highways. The 1940s, 50s and 60s were the golden age of road travel. Cars had become cheap and roomy enough to carry families comfortably for hundreds of miles. The Interstate Highway System had started to connect the country's smaller roads into a vast nationwide network. Finally, tourists could make their way from New York to California, with the windows down and the wind in their hair, seeing the grandeur of America along the way.
这里是《99%隐形》（99% Invisible）。我是罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）。这是美国梦，是轮子上的自由，是汽车时代，是在节省时间的超级高速公路上旅行。20世纪40、50和60年代是公路旅行的黄金时代。汽车变得便宜且宽敞，足以让家庭舒适地行驶数百英里。州际公路系统开始将全国的小路连接成一个庞大的全国性网络。终于，游客们可以从纽约开车到加利福尼亚，摇下车窗，任风吹拂头发，沿途领略美国的壮丽景色。
We have become the nation on wheels with more motorized mobility than ever dreamed of before. But of course, this freedom and mobility wasn't available to everyone. That's our brand new producer and splash of cold water, Delaney Hall. Because in 1956, the year that federal funding made the interstate highway system possible, Jim Crow was still the law of the land. In the south, racial segregation was enforced by law,
我们已经成为一个轮子上的国家，拥有前所未有的机动性。但当然，这种自由和机动性并非人人都能享有。这是我们全新的制作人，也是一盆冷水，德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）。因为在1956年，即联邦拨款使州际公路系统成为可能的那一年，“吉姆·克劳法”（Jim Crow）仍然是国家的法律。在南方，种族隔离是由法律强制执行的，
and had been since shortly after reconstruction. In many parts of the north, the codes were enforced in practice. And these codes could make a simple road trip really complicated for black travelers. How is this? Is that a good level? Is all you picking me up well there? This is Curtis Graves. Okay, my name is Curtis Graves and I was born in 1938, so I'm a little older than most of the people who are listening to this. Curtis would eventually become a Texas state representative, and then he'd go on to work
而且自重建时期后不久就开始了。在北方的许多地方，这些准则在实践中被强制执行。而这些准则会让黑人旅行者的一次简单公路旅行变得非常复杂。这是什么？这个音量可以吗？你听得清楚吗？这是柯蒂斯·格雷夫斯（Curtis Graves）。好的，我叫柯蒂斯·格雷夫斯，我出生于1938年，所以我比大多数听众都要年长一些。柯蒂斯后来成为了德克萨斯州的众议员，然后他继续在
at NASA, and then he'd become a photographer. But as a kid, he grew up in the segregated south. And for many years, his parents tried to shield him from that reality. I've often said that both my mother and father were the best liars that I knew. For instance, we sat in the back of the bus because it was cooler there. We rode in the front of the train because you could get off quicker. We sat upstairs in the movie because you had better seats in the upstairs. Of course, that ruse couldn't last.
美国国家航空航天局（NASA）工作，后来成为了一名摄影师。但作为一个孩子，他在种族隔离的南方长大。多年来，他的父母一直试图保护他免受那种现实的影响。我常说，我的母亲和父亲是我认识的最好的骗子。例如，我们坐在公共汽车的后排，因为那里更凉快。我们坐在火车的头等车厢，因为那样下车更快。我们坐在电影院的楼上，因为楼上的座位更好。当然，这种诡计不可能永远持续下去。
And by the time Curtis was a college senior in Houston, Texas, in the mid-1950s, he was fully aware of what it meant to be a black person living under Jim Crow. There's one experience in particular that stands out in his mind. He was just 21 years old and getting ready to drive to a college meeting in Waco, about three hours northwest of Houston.
到柯蒂斯在20世纪50年代中期成为德克萨斯州休斯顿的一名大学四年级学生时，他已经完全意识到作为一名生活在“吉姆·克劳法”下的黑人意味着什么。有一段经历尤其让他记忆犹新。他当时只有21岁，正准备开车去参加在韦科（Waco）举行的一次大学会议，那里在休斯顿西北方向约三小时车程的地方。
He'd agreed to take a couple of acquaintances. They happened to be white women. I said to myself, I might be in for some difficult times here, but I had to sew John. To get to Waco, Curtis had to drive through a stretch of East Texas that was notorious in those decades for racial violence. Oh yeah, those communities were pretty bad.
他同意带几个熟人。她们恰好是白人女性。我对自己说，我可能要面临一些困难了，但我必须送约翰。为了到达韦科，柯蒂斯必须开车穿过德克萨斯州东部的一段路，那段路在那些年代以种族暴力而闻名。哦，是的，那些社区相当糟糕。
Around dusk the travelers got hungry, so they pulled over at a roadside diner. As soon as we got in the front door, the guy said, ah, sorry, but you can't come in here. We don't serve black people at all. So the three of them went back outside and Curtis devised a plan. They'd try another restaurant right across the street. I said to them, the two of you go in, get a table. And after you're seated and the waiter or waitress comes up to you,
黄昏时分，旅行者们饿了，于是他们把车停在路边的一家餐馆。我们刚进前门，那个人就说，啊，抱歉，但你们不能进来。我们根本不接待黑人。于是他们三个人回到外面，柯蒂斯想出了一个计划。他们要尝试街对面的另一家餐馆。我对她们说，你们两个进去，找张桌子。等你们坐下，服务员过来的时候，
tell them that you have a boy that's driving you, and that you want to know whether he can, you can bring him in to eat. So the women walked inside, and they asked the waitress if Curtis could come inside to join them. And the lady said, of course, no problem at all. So as long as I was that boy and their driver,
告诉他们你们有一个开车的小伙子，想知道能不能带他进来吃饭。于是女士们走进餐馆，问服务员柯蒂斯是否可以进来和她们一起。那位女士说，当然，没问题。所以，只要我是那个小伙子，是她们的司机，
I could eat with them at a table in a restaurant, but if I were equal to them, I could not. This kind of humiliation on the road was routine and had been going on for decades. Many people wrote into the NAACP around this time describing experiences just like curtices. To hold on, make him certain, before starting our recent vacation trip to several
我就能和她们坐在餐馆里吃饭，但如果我和她们平等，我就不能。这种在路上的羞辱是家常便饭，而且已经持续了几十年。当时许多人写信给全国有色人种协进会（NAACP），描述了和柯蒂斯一样的经历。等等，在他开始我们最近去几个
Eastern states. Yes sir, I am a member of the NAACP and in a call. I would like to report an incident occurring on January 1st at a golf service station in Macon, Georgia. My wife and I went to the restaurant to refresh ourselves, then found a vacant table 10 minutes past and no one came to service. I keep. He informed me that the restroom for the color was in the back.
东部州的度假旅行之前，请确保他……是的，先生，我是NAACP的成员。我想报告1月1日发生在佐治亚州梅肯市一家海湾服务站（Gulf service station）的事件。我和妻子去餐馆休息，然后找了一张空桌子，过了10分钟没人来服务。他通知我，有色人种的洗手间在后面。
It seems to me dealers should not be permitted to sell gas and oil and not provide these comforts for us also. Some travelers would drive all night instead of trying to find lodging in an unfamiliar and possibly dangerous town. They'd pack picnics so they didn't have to stop for food. Some people would even carry portable toilets in the trunks of their cars, knowing that there was a good chance they'd be turned away from roadside restrooms. But since 1936, a guy named Victor Hugo Green had been trying to help with some of these
在我看来，经销商不应该被允许销售汽油和机油，却不为我们提供这些便利。一些旅行者会整夜开车，而不是试图在一个陌生且可能危险的城镇寻找住宿。他们会打包野餐，这样就不必停下来吃饭。有些人甚至会在汽车后备箱里携带便携式马桶，因为他们知道很有可能被路边的洗手间拒之门外。但自1936年以来，一个叫维克多·雨果·格林（Victor Hugo Green）的人一直在试图帮助解决其中一些
problems, to make life easier for thousands of black motorists. State by State, he'd been putting together a travel guide with listings of restaurants, hotels, and service stations that would welcome African-American travelers. He called it the Negro Motorist Green book. The green book for short. Victor Green, who died in 1960, lived in Harlem, New York during the height of the Harlem Renaissance. His apartment was not far from Duke, Elingtons. His office would eventually be situated near smalls paradise, a famous nightclub. Victor didn't have the most obvious background for starting a travel guide. He didn't work in tourism, he wasn't a writer, he was a mailman in Hackensack, New Jersey.
问题，让成千上万的黑人驾车者生活得更轻松。他逐州整理了一份旅行指南，列出了欢迎非裔美国旅行者的餐馆、酒店和服务站。他称之为《黑人驾车者绿皮书》（The Negro Motorist Green Book），简称《绿皮书》。维克多·格林于1960年去世，他在哈莱姆文艺复兴时期住在纽约哈莱姆区。他的公寓离艾灵顿公爵（Duke Ellington）的住处不远。他的办公室最终设在著名的夜总会“斯莫尔天堂”（Small's Paradise）附近。维克多并没有从事旅行指南工作的明显背景。他不从事旅游业，也不是作家，他是新泽西州哈肯萨克的一名邮递员。
But he kept hearing stories about discrimination on the road. So he would go do his route in Hackensack, New Jersey, come back home and work on a green book at night, compiling these addresses, typing them up and putting them in a book form. This is Calvin Alexander Ramsey, playwright, author and filmmaker. And years ago, Calvin started researching the history of the green book. He learned that the green book wasn't really the first guide of its kind. In fact, Victor may have gotten the idea from Jewish travelers. Because the Jewish community was also having issues on the open road with a lot of the places
但他不断听到关于路上歧视的故事。所以他会在新泽西州哈肯萨克送信，晚上回家后研究《绿皮书》，汇编这些地址，打字并整理成书。这是卡尔文·亚历山大·拉姆齐（Calvin Alexander Ramsey），剧作家、作家和电影制作人。多年前，卡尔文开始研究《绿皮书》的历史。他了解到《绿皮书》并不是同类指南中的第一本。事实上，维克多可能是从犹太旅行者那里得到的灵感。因为犹太社区在公路上也遇到了很多地方
saying restricted, and that was a code word for Gentiles only. When Victor published his first green book, it just covered New York. And he heard from around the country from other carriers and other people saying we really need this nationwide. But it wasn't that easy to gather information from across the country back then long distance phone calls were expensive and that Calvin says is when Victor Green realized that being a mailman was his secret superpower They were afkamerican let a carriers all over the United States at this time. We're talking about 1936 and so he knew about you know African-American letter carriers all over the United States at this time. We're talking about 1936. And so he knew about, you know, the relationships that the male men have with their
被标记为“限制性”的问题，那是“仅限外邦人”的代号。当维克多出版第一本《绿皮书》时，它只涵盖了纽约。他从全国各地的其他邮递员和其他人那里听说，我们确实需要全国性的指南。但当时从全国各地收集信息并不容易，长途电话很贵。卡尔文说，就在那时，维克多·格林意识到，身为邮递员是他的秘密超能力。当时全美各地都有非裔美国邮递员。我们说的是1936年，所以他知道……你知道，当时全美各地都有非裔美国邮递员。我们说的是1936年。所以他知道，你知道，邮递员与他们的
homeowners or apartment dwellers delivering their mail. So just like today, the male man is part of the community. So Calvin says Victor tapped into this network, spreading the word about his guide through the National Alliance of Postal and Federal Employees, a letter carrier union. Calvin says postal workers across the country scouted potential green book locations in their cities and towns. He says that some even asked families they delivered to, if they'd be open to hosting travelers in their homes. And if they agreed, then they would send the information to Victor Green in Harlem. Victor was able to get a fill force of let it carriers who are all over the country, who acquired materials and names and addresses and businesses for him. Wherever they were, the black male man, you had a Green Book salesman or recruiter.
房主或公寓住户在投递邮件时建立的关系。所以就像今天一样，邮递员是社区的一部分。卡尔文说，维克多利用了这个网络，通过全国邮政和联邦雇员联盟（一个邮递员公会）传播关于他的指南的消息。卡尔文说，全国各地的邮政工作人员在他们所在的城市和城镇搜寻潜在的《绿皮书》地点。他说，有些人甚至询问他们投递邮件的家庭是否愿意在家里接待旅行者。如果他们同意，他们就会把信息发送给哈莱姆区的维克多·格林。维克多能够获得一支遍布全国的邮递员队伍，他们为他获取了材料、姓名、地址和企业信息。无论他们在哪里，只要有黑人邮递员，你就有了一个《绿皮书》推销员或招募员。
Pretty quickly, the Green Book salesman or recruiter. Pretty quickly the Green Book caught on. Businesses, many black owned, began getting in touch with Victor, hoping to advertise and hoping to be listed. Black newspapers signed on as sponsors. Victor eventually retired from his job as a letter carrier and started working on the guide full time. He even opened an affiliated travel agency that helped tourist arrange trips.
很快，《绿皮书》就流行起来了。许多黑人拥有的企业开始与维克多联系，希望做广告并被列入名录。黑人报纸也签约成为赞助商。维克多最终从邮递员的工作中退休，开始全职从事指南的工作。他甚至开设了一家附属旅行社，帮助游客安排行程。
But still there was the challenge of distribution. How to get the guide into the hands of travelers who needed it. That happened in a few ways. The United States travel bureau signed on to help out, and then there were the more informal networks. Well churches, Pullman porters, the Urban League, the NWCP, the Masonic lodges, there was a very wide, very distribution process in place for these green books. And there was an important corporate sponsor too, a big one. And gas, that's extra fine. There's a smile for every mile at the SO sign.
但仍然存在分销的挑战。如何将指南送到需要它的旅行者手中。这通过几种方式实现。美国旅游局签约提供帮助，然后还有更非正式的网络。嗯，教堂、普尔曼列车服务员（Pullman porters）、城市联盟（Urban League）、NAACP、共济会会所，这些《绿皮书》有一套非常广泛的分销流程。还有一个重要的企业赞助商，一个大赞助商。还有汽油，那是特级的。在SO标志下，每一英里都有一个微笑。
The S-S-O makes your car go! And be mortering! SO, also known as Standard Oil, and now known as ExxonMobile, was one of the few oil companies back then that actively pursued black customers. They franchised their stations to African-American operators, and they had a black representative on staff, James Billboard Jackson, who helped place green books in many of those stations, as well as the White Own ones. S.O. may have done this out of a sense of fairness and equality.
S-S-O让你的车跑起来！还有汽车！SO，也就是标准石油公司（Standard Oil），现在被称为埃克森美孚（ExxonMobil），是当时少数几家积极争取黑人客户的石油公司之一。他们将加油站特许经营给非裔美国经营者，并且在员工中有一位黑人代表，詹姆斯·比尔博德·杰克逊（James Billboard Jackson），他帮助将《绿皮书》放置在许多这些加油站，以及白人拥有的加油站中。SO这样做可能是出于一种公平和平等的意识。
John DeRocquefeller, who founded Standard Oil in 1870, had married into a family of abolitionists who were part of the underground railroad, and he'd voted for Abraham Lincoln back in the day. But SO probably did it for another reason too. Money honey, it has to do with money. Remember Curtis, who had the crappy experience driving across East Texas? His dad operated one of the first black owned SO associations in New Orleans where Curtis was born and raised. It was called Bootsie and Buddies. The economic logic of stocking the green book was pretty simple, he says.
1870年创立标准石油公司的约翰·洛克菲勒（John D. Rockefeller），娶了一个废奴主义者家庭的女儿，他们是地下铁路的一部分，而且他当年还投票支持过亚伯拉罕·林肯。但SO这样做可能还有另一个原因。钱，亲爱的，这和钱有关。还记得那个在德克萨斯州东部开车经历糟糕的柯蒂斯吗？他的父亲在柯蒂斯出生和长大的新奥尔良经营着第一批黑人拥有的SO加油站之一。它叫“靴子和伙伴”（Bootsie and Buddies）。他说，储备《绿皮书》的经济逻辑很简单。
If you want black people to buy your fuel, why don't you give them an opportunity to see that they can travel and find places to stay while they're on the road traveling. So Curtis's dad kept a shelf of green books for his customers. You know, somebody came in and said, buddy, I'm thinking about taking a trip to Chicago, my dad would say, well, do you know where to stop between here in Chicago? And the person would say say no, he said well here, the green book will tell you.
如果你想让黑人购买你的燃料，为什么不给他们一个机会，让他们看到他们可以旅行并找到住宿的地方呢？所以柯蒂斯的父亲为他的客户保留了一架《绿皮书》。你知道，如果有人进来问，伙计，我正考虑去芝加哥旅行，我父亲会说，好吧，你知道在去芝加哥的路上哪里可以停吗？那个人会说不知道，他说，好吧，给你，这本《绿皮书》会告诉你。
And it gave you a sense of security. And so the green book came to cover listings in all 50 states and even some locations in Canada, the Caribbean and Mexico. They printed about 15,000 copies a year. Victor Green had changed travel for thousands of African-American tourists. He wrote in a 1956 introduction to the guide. Now, things are different. The Negro traveler can depend on the Green Book for all the information he wants.
它给了你一种安全感。于是《绿皮书》涵盖了所有50个州的列表，甚至包括加拿大、加勒比地区和墨西哥的一些地点。他们每年印刷约15,000份。维克多·格林改变了成千上万非裔美国游客的旅行方式。他在1956年指南的序言中写道：现在，情况不同了。黑人旅行者可以依靠《绿皮书》获取他想要的所有信息。
This guide has made traveling more popular without encountering embarrassing situations. But as the civil rights struggle continued, some people began to question the value of the Green Book. A black people many of them began to feel that this was accommodating to Jim Crow. Susan Rue is a professor of history at Brigham Young University, and she says that the Green Book began to seem a little out of step with the Times. It rarely took on an overtly political tone, especially in its early days. And there were actually other black travel guides
这本指南让旅行变得更受欢迎，而不会遇到尴尬的情况。但随着民权斗争的继续，一些人开始质疑《绿皮书》的价值。许多黑人开始觉得这是在迁就“吉姆·克劳法”。苏珊·鲁（Susan Rue）是杨百翰大学的历史学教授，她说《绿皮书》开始显得有点与时代脱节。它很少采取公开的政治立场，尤其是在早期。事实上，当时还有其他黑人旅行指南
published around the same time that did. One called travel guide, for instance. Travel guide listed where the NAACP chapters were in each city. They were much more attuned with civil rights, much more political tone. Eventually, the NAACP made it clear. And the NAACP said, what we're striving for, we're striving for integration.
在同一时期出版，它们确实采取了政治立场。例如，有一本叫《旅行指南》（Travel Guide）的刊物。它列出了每个城市NAACP分会的位置。它们更关注民权，政治色彩更浓。最终，NAACP明确表示了立场。NAACP说，我们所争取的是融合。
And so that's their stand. And the NAACP built a lot of their push for the 1964 Civil Rights Act, which outlawed discrimination based on race, and ended Jim Crow around this idea of total integration. In fact, when the NAACP testified during the debate over the bill, they drew on all those letters they'd received about discrimination on the road. They appealed to that vision of the iconic family road trip of the Freedom to Explore America by Car. Roy Wilkins, the executive secretary of the NAACP, spoke before the Senate's Commerce Committee in 1963. As soon as Congress gets out, they're all gonna head into their station wagons and go back to their home district. It's July in Washington. It's really hot.
这就是他们的立场。NAACP将他们推动1964年《民权法案》（该法案取缔了基于种族的歧视，并结束了“吉姆·克劳法”）的大部分努力建立在全面融合的理念之上。事实上，当NAACP在法案辩论期间作证时，他们利用了他们收到的所有关于路上歧视的信件。他们呼吁人们关注标志性的家庭公路旅行愿景，即开车探索美国的自由。NAACP执行秘书罗伊·威尔金斯（Roy Wilkins）于1963年在参议院商业委员会前发言。国会一休会，他们都会开着旅行车回到各自的选区。那是七月的华盛顿，非常热。
Wilkins us the Senate to imagine what it might be like to travel as a black person. Would you like me to read what Roy Wailton said? How far do you drive each day? Where and under what conditions can you and your family eat? Where can they use a restroom? Can you stop driving after a reasonable day behind the wheel? Or must you drive until you reach a city where relatives or friends will accommodate you and yours for the night? Will your children be denied a soft drink
威尔金斯要求参议院想象一下作为黑人旅行会是什么样子。你想让我读读罗伊·威尔金斯说了什么吗？你每天开车多远？你和你的家人在什么条件下可以吃饭？他们可以在哪里使用洗手间？你可以在开车一天后停下来吗？还是你必须一直开到有亲戚或朋友能为你和你的家人提供过夜住宿的城市？你的孩子会被拒绝买汽水
or an ice cream cone because they are not white? So he's appealing to them and at the most basic level of their own love for their own family. And Susan thinks this may have been one of the things that helped pass the bill. By framing the narrative of civil rights as a family travel narrative, they were able to convince the senators to vote for the bill. In 1964, President Lyndon Johnson signed the bill into law. Congress passes the most sweeping civil rights bill ever to be written into the law, and thus
或冰淇淋蛋筒，仅仅因为他们不是白人吗？所以他是在呼吁他们，在他们对自己家庭的热爱这一最基本的层面上。苏珊认为这可能是帮助法案通过的原因之一。通过将民权叙事构建为家庭旅行叙事，他们成功说服了参议员们投票支持该法案。1964年，林登·约翰逊总统签署了该法案，使其成为法律。国会通过了有史以来最广泛的民权法案，从而
reaffirms the conception of equality for all men that began with Lincoln and the Civil War 100 years ago. The Negro won his freedom then. He wins his dignity now. The Civil Rights struggle was not over then and it's still not over today. But for Victor Green, it became clear at some point that his Green Book had a limited shelf life. He wrote in the introduction to one of his guides.
重申了100年前林肯和内战开始时所有人都平等的构想。黑人在那时赢得了自由。他现在赢得了尊严。民权斗争在那时并没有结束，今天也还没有结束。但对于维克多·格林来说，在某个时刻，很明显他的《绿皮书》寿命有限。他在其中一本指南的序言中写道：
There will be a day sometime in the near future, when this guide will not have to be published. That is when we, as a race, will have equal opportunities and privileges in the United States. In sure enough, two years after the Civil Rights Act passed, the Green Book published its last edition. So, actually, could you just describe where we are? We're at the public library, downtown, the central branch in Los Angeles, and we're down in the bowels for floors down underground in the history and genealogy department.
在不久的将来，总有一天这本指南将不再需要出版。那就是当我们作为一个种族，在美国拥有平等机会和特权的时候。果然，在《民权法案》通过两年后，《绿皮书》出版了最后一版。那么，实际上，你能描述一下我们在哪里吗？我们在洛杉矶市中心的公共图书馆，中央分馆，我们在地下四层的历史和家谱部门。
You have a stack of books there in front of you. What are those? They are green books. They're just little jewels. I mean, I just buzzed with this kind of good energy that I just feel like, oh my god, they're actually here. It's amazing, it's amazing. Kandace Taylor is a photographer and a cultural documentarian.
你面前有一叠书。那些是什么？它们是《绿皮书》。它们就像小珠宝。我的意思是，我被这种美好的能量所感染，我感觉，哦天哪，它们真的在这里。太神奇了，太神奇了。坎迪斯·泰勒（Kandace Taylor）是一位摄影师和文化纪录片制作人。
The guide she's holding are small, maybe eight inches by five inches. They have green covers, each with a different destination featured. And there are pages and pages of listings inside. Let me see. There were beauty parlors, barbershops, tailors, taverns. There were nightclubs.
她手里拿着的指南很小，大约8英寸乘5英寸。它们有绿色的封面，每一本都有不同的目的地。里面有页复一页的列表。让我看看。有美容院、理发店、裁缝店、酒馆。还有夜总会。
It was really a social network. It was anything you might want to do in that town and the resources that were available to you. Kandace has been traveling the country documenting old Green Book locations from California to Oklahoma to New Mexico. Many establishments are now run by people who don't know much if anything about the police's history. by people who don't know much if anything about the police's history. Some of the buildings are gone and what's left is just an empty lot or a patch of grass. Even these original copies of the guide are rare now. This Smithsonian bought one at auction recently. For $22,500. Wow. Yes. So look in your, if you're listening to this and you know your parents, you know, lived during Jim Crow, look in your adics and see you might have a, you know, 20 plus
它确实是一个社交网络。它是你在那个城镇可能想做的任何事情以及可供你使用的资源。坎迪斯一直在全国各地旅行，记录从加利福尼亚到俄克拉荷马再到新墨西哥的旧《绿皮书》地点。许多机构现在由对这段历史知之甚少甚至一无所知的人经营。有些建筑已经消失了，剩下的只是一块空地或一片草地。即使是这些原始版本的指南现在也很罕见。史密森尼学会最近在拍卖会上买了一本。花了22,500美元。哇。是的。所以看看你的……如果你正在听这个节目，并且你知道你的父母在“吉姆·克劳法”时期生活过，看看你的阁楼，你可能会发现一本价值2万多
thousand dollar guide you never know. Twenty thousand dollars is a lot of money, but back in 1936, when the green book first appeared and could be purchased for 25 cents by the travelers who needed it the most, it was arguably worth even more. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Delaney Hall, with Katie Mingle, Sam Greenspan, Avery Truffleman, Kurt Colstead, Sharif Yusef, and me Roman Mars. Thanks to backstory with the American History Guys for the recordings of the letters to the NAACP, read by Alicia Floyd, Stephen Toliver, and Leslie Tullifario, and Al Letson, who played
美元的指南，你永远不知道。两万美元是一大笔钱，但在1936年，《绿皮书》首次出现，最需要它的旅行者只需25美分就能买到时，它可以说价值更高。《99%隐形》本周由德莱尼·霍尔制作，凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）、萨姆·格林斯潘（Sam Greenspan）、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Truffleman）、库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colstead）、谢里夫·优素福（Sharif Yusef）和我罗曼·马斯共同参与。感谢《背景故事》（Backstory）和美国历史专家们提供的NAACP信件录音，由艾丽西亚·弗洛伊德（Alicia Floyd）、斯蒂芬·托利弗（Stephen Toliver）、莱斯利·图利法里奥（Leslie Tullifario）和阿尔·莱森（Al Letson）朗读，阿尔·莱森扮演了
the part of Victor Green. Thanks also to Orlando Gonzalez at the National Association of Letter Carriers and Jackie Moore at the National Alliance of Postal and Federal Employees. To find a link to Candacea Taylor's images of old Green Book locations and learn more about Calvin Ramsey's film about the Green Book, visit 99pi.org. We are a production of 99% Invisible Inca Project of KALW San Francisco and produced of the offices of our excite, and architecture and interiors firm. In beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California.
维克多·格林的角色。还要感谢全国邮递员协会的奥兰多·冈萨雷斯（Orlando Gonzalez）和全国邮政和联邦雇员联盟的杰基·摩尔（Jackie Moore）。要找到坎迪斯·泰勒拍摄的旧《绿皮书》地点的链接，并了解更多关于卡尔文·拉姆齐拍摄的关于《绿皮书》的电影，请访问99pi.org。我们是《99%隐形》的制作团队，这是旧金山KALW的一个项目，在我们的建筑和室内设计公司Our Excite的办公室制作。位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。
If you visit the brand new 99pi.org, you'll find new, non-audio articles with all the things you love about 99pi without me, rattling on. I'm really excited that we get to take on topics that are either too visual for the show or require such a quick turnaround that we just can't fit it into the audio show production schedule. But I also need to pay for it and we're trying out display ads. So if you have access to the marketing funds of a cool design-minded company and like supporting original and fun journalism about design for just pennies of you. Go to the sponsors page under the About menu at 99%invisible.org. It will be the best other people's money you've ever spent.
如果你访问全新的99pi.org，你会发现新的非音频文章，包含你喜欢《99%隐形》的所有内容，而无需听我唠叨。我非常兴奋，我们能够处理那些对节目来说太视觉化，或者需要如此快速周转以至于我们无法将其放入音频节目制作时间表的主题。但我也需要支付费用，我们正在尝试展示广告。所以，如果你能接触到一家酷炫的、具有设计思维的公司的营销资金，并且喜欢支持关于设计的原创和有趣的新闻报道，只需几分钱。请访问99invisible.org“关于”菜单下的赞助商页面。这将是你花过的最值得的别人的钱。
You can find this show and like the show on Facebook. We're all on Twitter, Instagram, and Spotify, but the best way to explore the 99% invisible activity that shapes the design of our world is to go to 99p i dot org. Radio TMP from PRX. Radio Tepi from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并点赞。我们都在Twitter、Instagram和Spotify上，但探索塑造我们世界设计的《99%隐形》活动的最好方式是访问99pi.org。来自PRX的Radio TMP。来自PRX的Radio Tepi。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。